Change is hard. When you want to make a change in your life, whether it's eating healthier food, starting an exercise program or saving more money, there are many human foibles that can stand in your way. Impulsivity, laziness, procrastination, or just plain forgetfulness are among them. Libraries are full of books offering multi-step plans and other tactics to inspire a new you. Often though, these plans fall flat. Our best intentions aren't enough to overcome the roadblocks of human nature that stand in our way. But in recent years, psychologists have begun to look at behavior change from a different angle. Instead of fighting human nature, this research suggests that we should analyze it and then leverage it to work for us rather than against us.
改变是艰难的。当你想要改变生活中的某样东西，不管是吃得更健康、开始锻炼计划还是存更多的钱，都有许多人类的缺点会阻碍你。冲动、懒惰、拖延或纯粹的健忘都在其中。图书馆里摆满了各种书籍，提供多步骤的计划和其他策略来激发一个全新的你。然而，这些计划往往收效甚微。我们最好的意愿不足以克服阻碍我们前进的人性路障。但在近年来，心理学家开始从不同的角度来看待行为改变。这项研究表明，我们不应该与人性对抗，而应该分析它，然后加以利用，让它为我们服务，而不是与我们作对。
What does that mean? What can we learn from the science of behavior change that can help us make the alterations we want to see in our lives? And how can organizations, companies, and governments use these insights to nudge whole populations into making better choices? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Katie Milkman, a professor at the Wharton School of the University of Pennsylvania and author of the book How to Change, the Science of Getting from Where You Are to Where You Want to be. Her research explores how insights from psychology and economics can be harnessed to change people's behavior for the better on both and an individual and a global scale. She has explored how relatively simple interventions can help
这是什么意思？我们能从行为改变科学中学到什么，从而帮助我们实现生活中希望看到的改变？组织、公司和政府又该如何利用这些见解来引导整个人群做出更好的选择？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，专门探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的教授凯蒂·米尔克曼（Katie Milkman）博士，她也是《如何改变：从现状到心之所向的科学》（How to Change, the Science of Getting from Where You Are to Where You Want to be）一书的作者。她的研究探讨了如何利用心理学和经济学的见解，在个人和全球范围内更好地改变人们的行为。她曾探讨过相对简单的干预措施如何能够帮助
people increase their savings, exercise more, and even get vaccinated, among other things. She is co-director of the Behavior Change for Good Initiative at Wharton. She also hosts the Charles Schwab podcast, Choiceology, about the science of decision-making. Dr. Milpman, thank you for joining us today. Thank you so much for having me. So as I said, your book is entitled How to Change, But in the first chapter, you start with a slightly different premise, which is when to change. You make the point that there are some moments in our lives that are particularly conducive to making change. What is your research found? And if you want to make a change in your life, when should you try to do it?
人们增加储蓄、多做运动甚至接种疫苗等。她是沃顿商学院“为善改变计划”（Behavior Change for Good Initiative）的联合主任。她还主持查尔斯·施瓦布（Charles Schwab）的播客《决策学》（Choiceology），该节目关于决策科学。米尔普曼博士，感谢你今天作客我们的节目。非常感谢邀请我。正如我所说，你的书名为《如何改变》，但在第一章中，你从一个略有不同的前提开始，那就是何时改变。你指出，我们生活中的某些时刻特别有利于做出改变。你的研究发现了什么？如果你想改变生活，什么时候应该尝试去做？
I love that you opened with this question because it's one of my favorite topics that I've studied. And actually, it was a question just like the one you asked that started me on this course. I was visiting Google presenting some of my work on nudges and choice architecture and strategies that could be used by HR managers to help their employees make better decisions and, you know, invest in new skills training, wellness programming, et cetera. And I was asked, is there some ideal time to encourage employees to change? And I realized, actually, there was very little I knew from the academic literature that would help me answer that great question.
我很高兴你以这个问题开场，因为这是我研究过最喜欢的课题之一。事实上，正是你刚才提出的这样一个问题，让我踏上了这条道路。当时我正在访问谷歌，展示我关于助推、选择架构以及HR经理可以用来帮助员工做出更好决策的策略的一些工作，比如投资新技能培训、健康计划等。有人问我，有没有什么理想的时间来鼓励员工做出改变？我意识到，实际上学术文献中几乎没有什么知识能帮我回答这个绝佳的问题。
So I went back to my research team at the University of Pennsylvania. my former student, Heng Chen Dai, who's now a professor at UCLA's Anderson School, and also Jason Reese, who's the head of behavioralize and a Wharton Senior Fellow. We were all really interested in behavior change. We started talking about this question and had really strong intuitions right away about when it might make sense to change. The first thing that came to mind for all of us was that we know people make more resolutions and set more goals around New Year's.
于是我回到了我在宾夕法尼亚大学的研究团队。我的前学生横川代（Heng Chen Dai），她现在是加州大学洛杉矶分校安德森商学院的教授，还有杰森·里斯（Jason Reese），他是behavioralize的负责人兼沃顿商学院高级研究员。我们都对行为改变非常感兴趣。我们开始讨论这个问题，并且立刻对什么时候适合改变产生了强烈的直觉。我们所有人脑海中浮现的第一件事是，我们知道人们在新年期间会做出更多决议并设定更多目标。
Right. So that was well established. We weren't coming up with something wildly new there. But what we got interested in is whether there was something about that moment that might give us a hint as to other moments in our lives when we might be more open to change. And we started reading the literature on autobiographical memory, the way people think about time. What we learned is that there are moments in our lives that feel like new beginnings. And that's because the way we organize time and our memory is as if our life is a series of chapters. and they have sort of beginnings,
对的。所以这是既定事实。我们在那里并没有提出什么疯狂的新东西。但让我们感兴趣的是，那个时刻是否存在某种特质，能够给我们一些线索，提示我们生活中还有哪些时刻可能让我们更乐于接受改变。我们开始阅读关于自传体记忆的文献，也就是人们思考时间的方式。我们了解到，我们生活中的某些时刻感觉像是新的开始。这是因为我们组织时间和记忆的方式，就好像我们的人生是一系列章节。它们有各自的起点、
middles and ends, that's how we think about ourselves like characters in a book instead of thinking about time really truly linearly. And as a result of that, any moment that feels like a break point can feel like a new beginning to us
中间和终点，这就是我们认为自己的方式，就像书中的角色一样，而不是真正按线性方式去思考时间。因此，任何感觉像是分水岭的时刻，都会让我们觉得是一个新的开始，
anytime we're opening a new chapter for any reason. And what happens at New Year's and what we found happens at some other moments as well is we feel like, you know, because we're closing a chapter, we can say that was the old me
无论何时，只要我们出于某种原因开启新的一篇。在新年期间发生的事情，以及我们发现也在其他某些时刻发生的事情是，我们觉得，你知道的，因为我们在合上一章，我们可以说那就是旧的我，
who didn't manage to quit smoking last year or didn't manage to go to that sky. skills training workshop. And the new me and the new year, you know, I'm, I'm different and I can do it. So we feel more optimistic. And we've found in our research that other moments that systematically feel like new beginnings to us and lead to a similar optimism and tendency to pursue goals include dates like just the start of a new week, the start of a new month, the celebration of a birthday, the celebration of certain holidays that we associate with new beginnings. So think more Labor Day and less Valentine's Day. And we've shown in our recent,
他去年没能成功戒烟，或者没能去参加那个技能培训研讨会。而新我和新年，你知道的，我，我是不同的，我能做到。所以我们感到更加乐观。我们的研究发现，其他系统性地让我们觉得是新的开始、并带来类似乐观情绪和追求目标倾向的时刻，还包括一些日期，比如新一周的开始、新一个月的开始、生日的庆祝活动、我们与新开始相关的某些假日的庆祝活动。所以想想劳动节多于情人节。我们在最近的研究中表明，
that people are more likely to do things like visit the gym at these moments, that they're more likely to set goals on a popular goal setting website around these dates that feel like new beginnings. And also if we reach out and say, when would you like to receive reminders to begin pursuing a goal or when would you like to start saving, for instance? And we simply label dates differently. If we label a date as an ordinary day, right, no special label, it's not nearly as attractive as if we give it a label that makes it feel like a new beginning. So, for example, in one study, we labeled March 20th as the first day of spring in one condition, but not in the other.
人们更有可能在这些时刻做一些事情，比如去健身房，在这些感觉像是新开始的日期前后，他们更有可能在一个受欢迎的目标设定网站上设定目标。而且，如果我们伸出双手询问，你希望什么时候收到提醒来开始追求目标，或者你希望什么时候开始储蓄？我们只是对日期进行了不同的标签化。如果我们把一个日期标记为普通的一天，对吧，没有特殊的标签，它就不如我们给它贴上一个让人感觉是新开始的标签那样具有吸引力。例如，在一项研究中，我们在一种情况下将3月20日标记为春天的第一天，但在另一种情况下没有。
It's the third Thursday in March. And we see really huge differences when it's labeled as the first day of spring and how attractive it is as a date to start pursuing a goal, for example. So we both see correlationally, sort of naturally people take advantage of these moments when they're looking at when to change. And we can run experiments and show that if we change the labels of the levels of the moment, associated with certain dates and add fresh start labels, dates that feel like a new beginning, we see this uptick. So taking that all together, it points to moments that feel like transitions
那是三月的第三个星期四。当它被标记为春天的第一天时，我们在它作为开始追求目标的日期的吸引力上看到了巨大的差异。因此，我们既看到了相关性，即人们在寻找何时改变时自然地利用这些时刻；我们也可以进行实验，表明如果我们改变与某些日期相关的时刻水平的标签，并添加重新开始的标签、即感觉像新开始的日期，我们就会看到这种上升趋势。因此，综合来看，它指向那些感觉像转折点的时刻，
feel like a new beginning of a chapter in our lives and particularly temporal landmarks that have those features that we've studied include the starts of these calendar cycles. Okay, but that's an external nudge in a sense. Now, what if I want to make a change, but there isn't some obvious fresh start right now, is there something that I can do for myself that would just create a fresh start? Yeah, it's a wonderful question. First of all, I would say there are so many dates that even though they are external, you can sort of look for the next one and jump on it, right? You know, Monday occurs every seven days, it turns out. So even though you have to wait around for seven days to start, they're fairly frequent. So I do think even with that constraint, they can be useful as moments to sort of
感觉就像我们生活中某一章节的新开始，特别是具有那些我们研究过的特征的时间地标，包括这些日历周期的开始。好的，但从某种意义上说，那是一个外部的助推。现在，如果我想做出改变，但现在并没有某个明显的全新开始，我能为自己做些什么来创造一个全新的开始呢？是的，这是一个极好的问题。首先，我想说的是，有那么多的日期，尽管它们是外部的，你基本上可以寻找下一个日期并抓住它，对吧？你知道，星期一每七天就会出现一次，事实证明。因此，即使你必须等待七天才能开始，它们的频率也相当高。所以即使有这个限制，我认为它们也可以作为用来锁定的有用时刻。
lock on to. In terms of whether you can create one for yourself, Heng Chen, who I mentioned my former student, who's, she did some work in her dissertation related to a slightly different kind of fresh start. She calls it a reset. And it's a different way that it's not a temporal landmark that wipes the slate clean, but rather some, a change in the way we're tracking our performance that can wipe the slate clean. So for instance, I wear a fit bit. And every morning, I sort of feel like I have a bit of a fresh start because yesterday, I, I had accumulated, you know, maybe a pathetically low number of steps, maybe a really high number of steps. Either way, I wake up and it says zero again. And that's a reset and a fresh start in a sense.
至于你是否能为自己创造一个，横琴——我提到我的前学生，她在一篇与略微不同的一种全新开始相关的博士论文中做了一些工作。她称之为重置（reset）。这是一种不同的方式，它不是一个擦干净石板的时间地标，而更像是一种我们追踪表现方式的改变，这可以擦干净石板。例如，我戴着Fitbit。每天早上，我都觉得自己有了一个全新的开始，因为昨天我，我积累的步数可能少得可怜，也可能多得惊人。不管怎样，我醒来时它又显示为零。从某种意义上说，这就是一次重置和全新的开始。
There's all these different ways in which we track our performance, whether it's sales performance, if you're in an organization, whether you're a professional athlete and you're just tracking your stats for the season. And things get reset at different frequencies, grades for students, whether it's semester, quarter. So one thing that we may have some more control over, especially for tracking ourselves, is when these resets occur. And if we're having a rough time, it turns out resets can be really valuable as a motivator to improve and set goals and do better. Interestingly, her research also finds that resets are harmful, and I think this is very
我们追踪表现的方式有各种各样不同的途径，无论是销售业绩（如果你在一个组织中），还是你是一名职业运动员，你只是在追踪自己这个赛季的数据。事情在不同的频率下重置，学生的成绩，无论是学期制还是季度制。因此，我们可能拥有更多控制权的一件事，特别是在追踪我们自己时，就是这些重置发生的时间。如果我们正经历一段艰难时期，事实证明，重置可以作为一种非常宝贵的动力，促使我们去改进、设定目标并做得更好。有趣的是，她的研究还发现，重置是有害的，我认为这实际上非常
intuitive, actually, in cases where we're doing really well. So you want to wipe the slate clean and have a fresh start when things aren't going your way, when you need the motivation to do something you haven't managed to do. but when you're on a role, it's actually disruptive and harmful to have a fresh start. So we do have to use this particular tool with some caution. You started out as an engineering student and you write in the book that in some ways you approach behavior change as an engineering problem. What do you mean by that? Yeah.
符合直觉，尤其是当我们做得很好的时候。所以，当事情不顺心时，当你需要动力去做一些你一直没能做到的事情时，你会想要一笔勾销并有一个全新的开始；但当你处于连胜状态时，有一个全新的开始实际上会带来干扰和危害。因此，我们在使用这个特定工具时确实必须保持一些谨慎。你最初是一名工程学学生，你在书中写到，你在某些方面将行为改变视为一个工程问题。你是什么意思？是的。
It's funny to be on this podcast and I'm often labeled a psychologist. You will laugh. I have literally never taken a psychology class in my entire life. My undergraduate degree and PhD are both in engineering. And so that's the, it's a different way of looking at the world. It's sort of looking for problems that you can solve by pulling the right pieces together in order to, you know, plug a hole or fix a gap or improve a structure. That is the way that I was trained to think. And it turns out, I think it's quite a useful way of looking at a lot of psychology problems,
参加这个播客很有趣，我经常被贴上心理学的标签。你会笑的。我一生中字面意义上从未上过一门心理学课。我的本科学位和博士学位都是工程学。所以那是，那是看世界的一种不同方式。它有点像在寻找问题，你可以通过把正确的零件拼凑在一起去解决它们，从而堵住一个漏洞、修复一个缺口或改善一个结构。这就是我受到的思维训练方式。事实证明，我认为这对于看待许多心理学问题是一种非常有用的方式，
especially in my field of behavioral science where we have spent a lot of time. documenting errors and judgment, the ways that people make systematic mistakes. But if you want to actually start correcting some of those mistakes, having this engineering mindset, like, you know, what, how can I build a structure that plugs that hole? How can I fill that gap is a really useful perspective, I think, and I've tried to bring that to my work. I've always been solutions oriented and looking for ways that what we know about the human mind not only presents conundrums and puzzles and problems and exposes limits, but also what we can do to actually overcome and build and grow and bridge those gaps.
特别是在我的行为科学领域，我们花了很多时间记录判断中的错误，以及人们犯系统性错误的方式。但如果你想真正开始纠正其中一些错误，拥有这种工程思维，比如，你知道，我如何建立一个结构来堵住那个漏洞？我该如何填补那个缺口？我认为这是一个非常有用的视角，我也一直在努力将这一点带入我的工作中。我一直是以解决方案为导向的，并寻找各种方法，让我们对人类心灵的了解不仅呈现出难题、困惑、问题和暴露出的局限性，而且还能让我们做些什么来真正克服、建立、成长并弥合这些鸿沟。
So some of your first research on behavior change was what you call temptation bundling, the idea for which came from something, a problem that you were trying to solve in your own life. Can you tell us that story and explain what temptation bundling is and how it can help people change their behavior? Yeah, I would love to. This is absolutely me search, which is a term I'm borrowing. I think another psychologist named Carrie Morwidge is the person who taught me that term. I love, I love that term. It's what drew me into the field, honestly, was that I was doing some me search. So I was a graduate student at the time in engineering and struggling with tough classes and tired at the
因此，你关于行为改变的一些早期研究是你所说的“诱惑捆绑”（temptation bundling），这个概念的灵感来自于你在自己的生活中试图解决的一个问题。你能给我们讲讲这个故事，并解释什么是“诱惑捆绑”以及它如何帮助人们改变行为吗？是的，我很乐意。这绝对是“自我搜索”（me search），这个词是我借来的。我想另一位名叫凯瑞·莫维奇（Carrie Morwidge）的心理学家是教给我这个词的人。我喜欢，我喜欢这个词。老实说，正是因为我在做一些自我搜索，才把我吸引到了这个领域。当时我是工程系的一名研究生，正在艰难地应付高难度的课程，并在漫长一天的
end of a long day. And all I wanted to do when I came home and should have been working on problem sets was curl up on my couch with, you know, entertainment, a juicy page turner or binge watch Netflix, one of the above. I was struggling to find the motivation to get my work done. Similarly, I knew that I really needed to exercise regularly. It was important for my physical and mental health. I was a lifelong athlete, but I just could not drag myself to the gym. And especially at the end of those long days when I was feeling worn out. I sort of had this epiphany, a little me search. And by the way, many other people have had this epiphany independently, which was, what if I only let myself enjoy these indulgent entertainment sources while I'm exercising?
结束时感到疲惫不堪。当我回到家，本该在做习题集的时候，我唯一想做的事就是蜷缩在沙发上，享受娱乐活动，看一本引人入胜的小说，或者疯狂追剧看Netflix，二者必居其一。我一直在努力寻找动力来完成工作。同样地，我知道我真的需要定期锻炼。这对我的身心健康很重要。我是一名终身运动员，但我就是无法把自己拖到健身房去。特别是经历那些漫长、感到筋疲力尽的日子之后。我有点像有了这个顿悟，一次小小的自我搜索。顺便说一句，许多其他人也独立地有了这个顿悟，那就是：如果我只允许自己在锻炼的同时享受这些纵容的娱乐资源呢？
Maybe that would actually drag me to the gym. And so, and maybe also I'd stop wasting time at home, binge watching TV when I should have been doing my problem sets. So I tried this out. I made a new rule that I was only allowed to indulge in entertainment while I was exercising. And it was life altering. All of a sudden, I'd come home from a long day, and all I wanted to do was rush to the gym to find out what happened and the latest. I was actually, I got into audio books, lowbrow audio books, like, well, this isn't very lowbrow. Harry Potter, James Patterson, you know, The Hunger Games, Page Turner's, thrillers. I would, I would want to know what happened next to these characters. So I'd dash off to the gym. I'd get in these great workouts where I didn't
也许这真的会把我拖到健身房去。而且，也许我也不会把时间浪费在家里疯狂看电视上，而我本该在做习题集的。所以我就尝试了这个方法。我制定了一条新规矩：我只有在锻炼时才能纵容自己享受娱乐。这改变了我的人生。突然之间，结束了一天的劳累回到家，我唯一想知道的事情就是赶快冲到健身房，看看最新进展中发生了什么。实际上，我迷上了有声书，低俗的有声书，比如，好吧，这其实不算太低俗。哈利·波特、詹姆斯·帕特森，你知道的，《饥饿游戏》，引人入胜的小说，惊悚小说。我会，我会想知道这些角色的下一步遭遇了什么。所以我就会冲向健身房。我在那里进行了极棒的锻炼，甚至没有
even notice that I was exercising, the time was flying so fast, normally exercise. was a drag, but I was so into these characters and the stories. I kept going. And then I'd come home and I was totally refreshed and rejuvenated, ready to get my work done and there's no distractions. And I thought, wow, this is really working for me. And I should see if this could help other people. So I ended up doing some experiments to test whether or not what I now call temptation bundling or linking something that you find a pleasure and a temptation with an activity that would otherwise feel like a chore in order to make it more, you know, endurable and more pleasant could help people. So we've run a couple of experiments now showing that temptation bundling can be a
注意到自己在锻炼，时间飞逝，通常锻炼是一件很痛苦的事，但我太沉迷于这些角色和故事了。我坚持了下去。然后我回到家，整个人完全神清气爽、焕发活力，准备好完成我的工作，而且没有任何干扰。我想，哇，这对我真的很管用。我应该看看这能否帮助其他人。于是我最终做了一些实验来测试，我现在所说的“诱惑捆绑”——将你觉得是乐趣和诱惑的事情，与本来会感觉像是一项杂务的活动结合起来，使其变得更，你知道的，更能忍受、更愉快，是否能帮助人们。所以我们现在已经做了一些实验，表明“诱惑捆绑”可以成为
helpful tool to other people, not just me, not an end of one. So one experiment, the first one we did, we randomly assigned people to a group where they would be given tempting audio novels that they could load onto iPods and then listen to the first 30 minutes while they were doing a workout at the gym. And we told them if they wanted to hear what happened next in whichever tempting novel they'd picked from a menu of 80 we gave them that had been pre-tested, well, they would have to come back to the gym because we'd be holding their iPod hostage in a locked monitored locker they could only access when they came in for a workout. And we compared that group's exercise habits to a control group that also did a 30-minute workout at the start, also owned iPods, was also given an equally
对其他人有帮助的工具，不仅仅是对我，不是一个人的孤例。所以，我们做的第一个实验，是将人们随机分配到一个小组中，他们会得到诱人的有声小说，可以下载到iPod上，然后在健身房锻炼时听前30分钟。我们告诉他们，如果他们想从我们提供的80本经过预测试的诱惑小说菜单中挑选一本，并听听接下来发生了什么，好吧，他们必须回到健身房，因为我们会把他们的iPod扣押在一个锁好、有监控的储物柜里，只有当他们进来锻炼时才能打开。我们将这组人的锻炼习惯与一个对照组进行了比较，对照组在一开始也进行了30分钟的锻炼，也拥有iPod，同样获得了价值相等的礼物——巴诺书店（Barnes & Noble）的礼品卡，当然，如果他们愿意，他们可以用它来买有声书。但我们没有向他们提出“诱惑捆绑”的建议。我们发现，“诱惑捆绑”确实在短期内相当显著地增加了锻炼。因此，这项研究持续了10周。这些效果在7周内保持稳健。接着感恩节假期来了。我们做实验的是大学健身房。健身房关门了。每个人都回家了。这实际上也是，我认为这项研究中另一个有趣的部分，这种效果完全被那段与诱惑性刺激被迫隔离的时期抹去了。所以，你知道的，我们做过后续研究，表明当你没有那种中断时，它可以产生更持久的效果；但
valued gift, a gift certificate to Barnes & Noble, which they could, of course, used to buy audiobooks if they wanted. But we gave them no suggestion to Temptation Bundle. And what we found is that temptation bundling did increase exercise pretty substantially in the short term. So the study went for 10 weeks. The effects were robust for seven weeks. Then along came Thanksgiving break. We did the city university gym. The gym closed. Everybody went home. And this was actually, I think, another interesting part of the research, the effect was totally wiped out by that period of forced separation from the tempting stimulus. So, you know, we've done subsequent studies where we show it can have a more durable effect when you don't have that kind of disruption. But
这也回到了我们之前讨论的关于全新开始的话题，以及重置和中断在某些情况下是好的，但在你处于连胜状态时却是有害的。这样一来，你为了去健身房就有点依赖你的iPod了。如果没有它，当你回家时，那就忘了吧。我做不到了。完全正确。完全正确。而且无论如何，所有这些事情，我认为，使它们如此有趣的一部分原因在于，很少有完全明确、总是管用的事情。
it also links back to what we were talking about with fresh starts and how resets and disruption can be good in some cases, but when you're on a role can be harmful. You get kind of dependent then on your iPod in order to go to the gym. If you don't have it, when you go back home, forget it. I'm done. Exactly. Exactly. And there's, anyway, all these things I think, part of what makes them so interesting is there's, there are a few things that are just sort of totally unambiguous, always work.
没有调节变量。这也是研究人类如此有趣的一点，那就是总有有趣的复杂性需要去剖析。无论如何，这就是关于“诱惑捆绑”的工作，我之前只在锻炼的背景下谈论过它，但我只是想向那些有其他类型行为的听众指出，他们觉得这些行为是杂务或负担，而他们正试图更多地参与其中。从理论上讲，这是一个适用于生活中许多环境的工具，不仅仅是让你自己去健身房。因此，你可以考虑只允许自己听最喜欢的播客，比如在做家务或烹饪新鲜饭菜时听这个，
There's no moderators. And that's one of the things that's so interesting about studying humans is that there's always interesting complexity to unpack. Anyway, so that's the work on temptation bundling, and I've talked about it only in the context of exercise, but just want to point out for listeners who have other kinds of behaviors that they find to be chores or burdens, and they're trying to engage in more. It's a tool that theoretically should be applicable to lots of settings in life, not just getting yourself to the gym. So you can think about only letting yourself listen to your favorite podcast, say this one while you're doing household chores or cooking fresh meals,
如果这些是你想要实现的目标，或者只允许自己在去图书馆啃书的路上买一份最喜欢的零食或点心（如果这感觉像是一项杂务，但你想要一些东西让它变得更愉快）。因此，除了锻炼之外，我们还可以通过很多方式创造“诱惑捆绑”，但这正是我最初做这件事并研究它的地方。所以你的书是按章节组织的，每一章涵盖人性的不同方面，我在引言中提到过其中的几个，比如冲动、懒惰、拖延。你能谈谈书中你最喜欢的例子吗？关于我们在试图做出改变时，如何顺应而不是对抗这些特质？
if those are goals that you want to fulfill, or only letting yourself pick up a favorite treat or snack on the way to hit the books at the library, if that feels like a chore, but you want something to make it more of a pleasure. So there's lots of ways we can create temptation bundles beyond exercise, but that is where I first did it and studied it. So your book is organized into chapters, each covering a different aspect of human nature, a couple of which I mentioned in the introduction, impulsivity, laziness, procrastination. Can you talk about your favorite examples from the book about how we can work with rather than against these traits when we're trying to make change?
是的，我最喜欢的例子可能是一个非常知名却又如此重要的例子。所以我无论如何都要唠叨一下。我认为这就是默认选项的力量。我认为这是来自行为科学的最大胜利之一，它与懒惰有关。总的来说，我们人类更喜欢
Yeah, probably my favorite example is one that is, it's really well known, and yet it's so important. So I'm just going to harp on it anyway. I think it's the power of defaults. And I think this is one of the biggest wins from behavioral science and it has to do with laziness. So in general, we humans prefer to. to take the path of least resistance, whatever the easiest route is to, you know, collecting my paycheck or getting my lunch or, you know, whatever it is, whatever goal you have, we're always looking for the shortcuts in the easiest way instead of the hardest work
走阻力最小的路线，无论最简单的路线是什么，比如领薪水、吃午餐，或者，无论是什么，无论你有什么目标，我们总是在寻找捷径和最简单的路线，而不是最辛苦的工作路线。而这实际上，当然是一个挑战，对吧？当谈到试图让自己保持极佳的身体状态，或者，你知道的，获得博士学位时，我们寻找捷径的事实并没有真正提供帮助，对吧？它通常是改变的障碍。所以我对此在书中谈了很多。但其中非常有趣的一点是，默认选项颠倒了这一点，将懒惰变成了一种资产。默认选项是指，如果你字面意义上一根手指都不抬、什么都不做，你在某种情况下最终会得到的选项。所以你的电脑出厂时带有默认设置，对吧？你打开它。它有一些背景屏幕。它有默认字体。它可能有一个默认浏览器。所有这些东西就都在那里。如果你走阻力最小的路线，
path. And that actually, of course, is a challenge, right? When it comes to trying to get yourself in great physical shape or, you know, earning your PhD, the fact that we're looking for shortcuts does not really help, right? It's often a barrier to change. And so I talk a lot about that in the book. But one of the things that's so interesting is that defaults, flip this on its head and turn laziness into an asset. So a default is the sort of option you will end up with in a situation if you literally don't lift a finger, if you do nothing. So your computer comes with default settings, right? You turn it on. It has some background screen. It has default fonts. It probably has a default browser. There's all these things that are just there. And if you take the path of least resistance,
好吧，这就是你最终得到的结果。所以我认为非常有趣的一点是，一旦你开始认识到它们的力量——它们已经在许多不同的环境中被研究过，这其实不是我研究过的东西，但这个协会里许多优秀的学者研究过。我只想提一下，例如，埃里克·约翰逊（Eric Johnson）和丹·戈德斯坦（Dan Goldstein）有一些非常精彩的研究，关于默认的器官捐赠政策在多大程度上改变了我们的决定。因此，在那些默认你成为器官捐赠者、但你可以通过勾选一个方框并在基本表格上签上名字这种极其简单的方式选择退出的国家，器官捐赠率要远高于那些你必须——我刚才说反了。不，我说对了，也就是你必须选择加入的国家，
well, that's what you end up with. And so I think one of the really interesting things is once you start to recognize their power and they've been studied in so many different contexts, it's actually not something I've studied, but lots of wonderful scholars in this association have. I'll just mention, for instance, Eric Johnson and Dan Goldstein have some wonderful work on how much default organ donation policies change our decisions. So countries where you're defaulted into being an organ donor, but you can just opt out trivially easily by sort of checking a box and signing your name on a basic form, have vastly higher rates of organ donorship than countries where you have to, I said it the wrong way. No, I said it the right way, where you have to opt in,
这就是我们在美国所拥有的。所以在美国，你去车管所（DMV），勾选一个方框，你选择加入。这极其简单，但我们的捐赠率较低，因为我必须采取某种行动，而我们总是寻找阻力最小的路线。所以无论如何，器官捐赠是一个特别棘手的问题，因为决定器官最终去向的因素不仅仅是你签名、勾选方框、选择加入或选择退出。但它展示了力量，因为默认政策存在这些巨大的差异，如果你想朝着积极的方向改变行为，深入思考这一点是多么重要。因此，当我们拥有旨在帮助人们实现目标的默认结构时，对吧？我们在默认选项中为他们提供
which is what we have in the United States. So in the United States, you go to the DMV, you check a box, you opt in. It's trivially easy, but we have lower donation rates because I had to take some action and we always look for the path of least resistance. So anyway, this is an organ donation is a particularly tricky one because it's more than just whether you sign your name and check a box and or opted in or opted out that determines what actually happens with organs. But it shows the power because of these huge differences of a default policy and how important it is to put deep thought into that if you want to change behavior in a positive direction. So when we have defaults that are structured to help people achieve their goals, right? We default them into getting
苹果切片配餐，而不是炸薯条作为配菜。或者我们默认人们成为器官捐赠者，尽管再次强调，那个问题有一些复杂性。所有这些选择，它们利用懒惰来帮助我们实现目标。例如，我的浏览器的首页不是Facebook或Twitter。它是《纽约时报》。所以每天当我打开它时，我都会遇到一些新闻，而不会被卷入某种可能会诱使我浪费时间的漩涡中。相反，我得到的是我认为丰富的内容。在你保持食物储备的储藏室里，你可以设置默认选项，这样你就很难买到你渴望的、对你不那么健康的汉堡和薯条或披萨。如果你想
apple slices with their meal instead of French fries on the side. Or we default people into, say, being organ donors, although again, that one has some complexity. All of those choices, they use laziness to help us achieve a goal. So for instance, my browser's homepage is not Facebook or Twitter. It's The New York Times. So every day I encounter some news when I open it up and I don't get sucked into a vortex of something that maybe I'm going to be tempted to waste time with. Instead, I'm getting something that I consider enriching. There's defaults you can have in your pantry in terms of what foods you keep on hand so that it's hard to get the burger and fries or the pizza that you crave that aren't as good for you. If you want to
保持健康，你的储藏室里就不会放饼干，而是放健康的零食。现在你的默认选项和阻力最小的路线与你的目标保持一致。因此，我认为这是一个非常强大的工具，一旦我们了解了懒惰的力量，并知道我们可以利用它并为我们所用，我们就可以用它来为我们的成功奠定基础。这也是一个让人们存钱的好方法。我的意思是，每个雇主不自动把你纳入401(k)计划，总是让我感到惊讶。你知道，你不会注意到它，对吧？
stay healthy, you don't have the cookies in the pantry, you have healthy snacks. And now your defaults and the path of least resistance is aligned with your goals. So I think that's a really powerful tool we can use to set ourselves up for success once we understand the power of laziness and that we can use it and harness it to our benefit. And that's a great one to get people to save as well. I mean, it always amazes me that every employer doesn't like automatically enroll you in the 401k plan. You know, you won't notice it, right?
而且我想你在那个领域也做过一些研究。绝对的。除了器官捐赠之外，最著名和最有用的例子之一可能是，雇主们——这是布里奇特·马德里安（Bridget Madrian）和丹尼斯·谢伊（Dennis Shea）的研究，大约在2003年左右首次展示了这一点——当时有一个雇主改变了做法，不再让新员工通过勾选方框和签名来注册（他们会将每笔薪水的一部分存入储蓄账户）。他们只是在文书工作上做了一个小小的改变，现在你必须勾选一个方框并签名以表示“我不想这样做”。一夜之间，他们发现401(k)计划的注册人数增加了近40%，这导致人们的退休储蓄大幅增加。所以现在公司将401(k)储蓄设为默认选项实际上是有税收优惠的。有一个——我相信2006年的《养老金保护法案》通过了，那是两党一致通过的。
And I think you've done some work in that area as well. Absolutely. Probably one of the most famous examples and most useful examples besides the organ donation is that employers, and this is worked by Bridget, Madrian and Dennis Shea, that first showed this in about, I think, 2003, when one employer switched from having new employees enroll by checking a box and signing their name, and they'd start having a portion of every paycheck sent to their savings account. They just made a little change in the paperwork, and now you had to check a box and sign your name to say, I don't want that done. And overnight, they saw almost a 40% increase in enrollment in their 401k program, which led to huge increases in people's savings for retirement. And so now it's actually tax advantage for companies to make savings in their 401K's the default. There was a – and the 2006 Pension Protection Act, I believe, passed that was nonpartisan.
每个人都同意，让我们利用懒惰来确保美国人拥有更好的财务安全。因此，这是一个极好的工具例子，决策者可以使用它。我们当然也可以自己使用它。就像你今天几乎可以进入任何银行账户，创建一个从一个账户到另一个账户的定期扣款或转账。一旦你设置了一次，你就再也不会去想它了。没有人会去改变这些东西，对吧？因为你很懒。你正走在阻力最小的路线。所以如果你只有一次，也许在某个充满动力想要提高储蓄率的全新开始时，你设置了从每笔薪水到不触碰的储蓄账户的自动扣款，你将
Just everyone agreed, let's harness laziness to make sure that Americans have better financial security. And so it's a terrific example of a tool that – policymakers can use. We can certainly also use it ourselves. Like you can go into almost any bank account today and create a recurring deduction from one, or movement from one to another. And once you've said it once, you'll never think about it again. No one's ever going and changing these things, right? Because you're lazy. You're on the path of least resistance. So if you're just one time, maybe at one fresh start when you're feeling motivated to increase your savings rate, you set up that auto deduction from every paycheck into a savings account that you don't touch, you are going to
积累更多。所以这真的是一个强有力的工具。这就引发了一个问题：个人如何确定在特定情况下行之有效的策略？我的意思是，对于想要做出改变的听众来说，为了找到适合自己的策略，他们在心理上应该经历什么？是的，我喜欢这个问题。老实说，这正是促成这本书写作的问题，在某种程度上，我觉得我意识到的是，当我与个人交谈时，当我与那些正在寻找行为改变挑战的组织交谈时——这也是我经常在研究中所做的——有一种倾向，即只是去寻找那些听起来不错、现成的解决方案，就好像，你知道的，也许它们在其他情况下已被证明是有效的，
accumulate more. So that's a really powerful tool. That raises a question around how an individual can identify strategies that are going to work in a particular situation. I mean, how, for the listener who wants to make a change, what should they be going through mentally in order to find that strategy that's going to work for them? Yeah, I love that question. Honestly, that is the very question that I would say to some degree was the impetus for writing the book, is that I felt like what I'd realized is when I talk to individuals, when I talk to organizations that were looking at behavior change challenges, which is what I often do in my research, there was this tendency to just sort of look for off-the-shelf solutions that sounded good and like, you know, maybe they'd
但几乎没有付出什么努力去诊断改变的障碍是什么。所以没有这种匹配。人们没有意识到，理解是什么在阻碍你，对于选择正确的工具来克服这一挑战是很重要的。所以我试着写这本书，实际上是为了，你知道的，既分享我职业生涯结束后所知道的关于科学和行为改变的一切，我也围绕着这一点进行了组织，即：有一套相当可预测的障碍，当你面临问题时，它们实际上是非常容易识别的，一旦你阅读了这本书或者读完了这个清单，
been proven effective in some other situation, but there was very little effort made to diagnose what was the barrier to change. So there wasn't this matching. Like there wasn't an appreciation that it mattered that you understood what was obstructing. you in order to choose the right tool to overcome that challenge. And so I tried to write this book to actually, you know, both share everything I knew about the science and behavior change after our career spending it, but also I organized it around, okay, there are a set of pretty predictable barriers that are actually very recognizable when you, when you are facing a problem, you will pretty easily, once you sort of have read the book or read through this list,
你就会说，“哦，对了，那是个健忘的问题。我不是，我晚上不吃药是因为我总是忘。不是因为它们有可怕的副作用而且让人痛苦。也不是因为我在拖延，因为我宁愿明天做也不愿今天做。那是健忘的问题。”一旦你认出了这些系统性问题的类型，其实就很容易看到并诊断出你正在面临哪种改变的障碍。一旦你知道了，就会有很多科学表明，好吧，如果这是一个健忘问题，这里有起作用的提醒种类、工具和策略。但如果它是拖延的障碍，你需要一套完全不同的策略。
you'll say, oh, yeah, like, that's a forgetting problem. I'm not, the reason I'm not taking me medications at night as I always forget. It's not that they have awful side effects and it's miserable. It's not that I'm procrastinating because I'd rather do it tomorrow than today. That's a forgetting problem. Sort of once you recognize the types of problems that are systematic, it's actually very easy to see and diagnose what kind of barrier you are facing to change. And then once you know it, there's a whole lot of science that suggests, okay, if it's a forgetting problem here, the kinds of reminders that work here, the tools and strategies. But if it's a barrier of procrastination, And you need a really different, different suite of strategies.
所以我想说，实际上诊断部分就像稍微接触一下一样简单。我写的书提供了这一点，但是，你知道的，获得心理学硕士学位，或者甚至拿起一本教科书了解判断决策文献。这并不难，也一点都不复杂。这只是我们通常会跳过的一个步骤。我们通常直接奔向：“哦，你知道的，我没有实现我的目标。我一定需要，你知道的，养成微习惯。”或者“我一定需要设定更大、更大胆的目标，或者想象成功”，而不是去想，“等等，好吧，在我试图解决这个问题之前，障碍是什么？”障碍会引导我找到正确的解决方案，因为解决方案有很多。有一大堆。所以你说过到处都是自助书。而且我想说，它们的许多解决方案都是以科学为基础的。只是它们很少深入探讨，比如，“哦，这只，你知道的，这确实是针对这类问题的解决方案。”关于同伴支持以及对另一个人做出承诺的想法呢？
So I would say actually the diagnosis part is as simple as having a little bit of exposure. And the book that I wrote provides that, but, you know, getting a master's in psychology or even picking up a textbook and learning about the judgment decision making literature. It's not, it's not hard or complex at all. It's just a step we normally skip. We normally go right for the, oh, you know, I'm not achieving my goals. I must need to, you know, build tiny habits. or I must need to set bigger, more audacious goals or visualize success instead of thinking, wait, okay, first before I try to solve this problem, what is the barrier? And the barrier is going to guide me towards the right solution because there are many solutions. There's a whole slew of them. And so you said there's self-help books all over the place. And lots of their solutions are science-based, I should say. It's just rarely do they get into like, oh, this only, you know, this is really a solution for this type of problem. What about peer support and the idea of making a commitment to another person?
我的意思是，如果你以某种方式承担责任，你是否更有可能坚持到底？是的。我就像，这是我能给你的最简单的答案。只有“是”。是的，我们继续吧。是的，当然，这比这更复杂。但是的，是的，是的，同伴支持太强大了。同伴支持有几个重要的组成部分。
I mean, if you're held accountable somehow, are you then more likely to follow through? Yes. I'm like, this is the easiest answer I get to give you. Just yes. Yeah, let's move on. Yes, of course, it's more complicated than that. But yes, yes, yes, peer support is so powerful. There's a couple of components of peer support that matter.
你提到了问责制。问责制绝对重要，因为当我们基本上增加了我们的不良习惯的代价时，对吧，无论是什么对你不好的事情，比如不学习、不为退休储蓄、不吃健康的饮食、或者不，你知道的，按时把报告交给老板。如果代价更大，那么你拖延和优先考虑当下有趣的事情而不是长远对你有益的事情的普遍倾向，嗯，代价越大，那件事发生的可能性就越小，对吧？所以你可以，你可以提高不良行为的代价，你就会看到更少的不良行为。这非常简单。而提高代价的一种方法就是问责制，因为羞耻感和觉得自己让别人失望的感觉，这些都是我们不愿意支付的高昂代价。所以绝对地，同伴支持之所以重要，原因之一就是它能创造问责制，
you touched on accountability. And accountability absolutely matters because when we basically increase the price of our vice, right, whatever the thing is that's bad for you, like not studying or not saving for retirement or not eating a healthy diet or not, you know, getting your report to your boss in time. If there's a bigger cost, then your general tendency to procrastinate and to prioritize what's fun in the moment instead of what's good for you in the long run, well, the bigger the cost, the less that, um, is likely to happen, right? So you can, you can up the cost of bad behavior and you'll see less of it. This is very simple math. And one way to up the cost is accountability because shame and feeling that you've let someone else down, those are big costs that we don't like to pay. So absolutely one of the reasons peer support matters is because it can create accountability
并且它能为未能坚持到底创造那些额外的代价。但除了问责制之外，同伴支持还有很多其他好处。其中最大的好处之一，我认为，已经被索洛蒙·阿什（Solomon Ash）等人在20世纪50年代进行了也许是最令人印象深刻的研究，最近罗伯特·查尔迪尼（Robert Chaldeeni）研究了社会规范。那就是当我们环顾四周，看到其他人——我们的同伴——在做什么，他们在取得什么成就时，它让我们了解了什么是正常的。这告诉我们什么是可能的，什么会受到社会的奖励，比如，你知道的，我们如何拥有朋友。所以你想融入其中，而且你实际上在别人的成就中看到了你自己的潜力。因此，当你拥有同伴群体并且你关注那些同伴群体并且他们了解你的目标时，不仅有问责制，而且你还可以通过其他方式建立同伴支持系统，并且你可以从同伴那里获得关于你在面对目标时能取得什么成就的宝贵知识。因此，认真思考一下，如果你能、如果你有权力以某种方式构建你的同伴群体，这真的很重要，
and it can create those extra costs for failing to follow through. But peer support has a lot of other benefits besides accountability. One of the biggest, I think, which has been studied maybe most impressively by folks like Solomon Ash in the 1950s, and then more recently sort of Robert Chaldeenie has studied social norms. And that is when we look around and see what other people, our peers, are doing, what they're achieving, it gives us knowledge about what's normal. And that tells us what's possible and what will be rewarded socially, like, you know, how we'll have friends. So you want to fit in, and you actually see what you're capable of in other people's achievements. So not only is there accountability when you have peer groups and you look to those peer
妈妈们知道这一点，爸爸们也知道这一点。抱歉，我有点性别歧视了。我丈夫在塑造我们儿子的同伴群体方面，在许多方面可能是一个比我参与更多的照顾者。所以思考一下你身边都是些什么人真的很重要。
groups and they know about your goals, but you can create peer support systems in other ways and you can gain valuable knowledge from your peers about what you can achieve when it comes to goals. So it's really important actually to think carefully if you can, if you have the power to structure your peer group in some way, and, you know, moms know this and dads know this too. Sorry to be sexist. My husband is a probably more engaged caregiver in many ways than I am shaping our sons, peer groups. So it's really important to think about who you're surrounded with.
群体，他们了解你的目标，但你可以通过其他方式建立同伴支持系统，并从同伴那里获得关于实现目标时可以达成什么的有价值的知识。因此，如果可以的话，如果你有能力以某种方式构建你的同伴群体，仔细思考其实非常重要，而且，你知道，妈妈们知道这一点，爸爸们也知道。抱歉我有点性别偏见。在塑造我们儿子的同伴群体方面，我的丈夫在很多方面可能比我更投入。所以，仔细思考你身边都是些什么人真的非常重要。
If you're surrounded with people who are role models who are showing you this is possible, you know, you want to run marathons, they're running marathons. They're, you know, they're really doing a great job or they're vegetarians. You want to be a vegetarian. That's the kind of lifestyle you aspire to lead. your peers show you the way and they can show you how to get where they are if you look and you can literally deliberately strategically copy and paste tactics that they use to successfully achieve their goals. So anyway, that was a long answer after yes, but peer support has a big role to play in
如果你周围都是一些为你树立榜样、向你展示这一切是可行的人，你知道的，比如你想跑马拉松，而他们在跑马拉松；他们，你知道的，他们真的做得很好，或者他们是素食主义者，你也想成为一名素食主义者——那是你渴望过的生活方式。你的同龄人为你指明了方向，如果你去观察，他们可以告诉你如何到达他们所在的地方，而且你可以字面意义上、刻意地、策略性地复制和粘贴他们用来成功实现目标的策略。总之，在回答“是”之后，这是一个很长的回答，但同伴支持在其中扮演着重要的角色。
behavior change. So that brings me then to vaccine uptake, okay, because a lot of the thinking at early in the pandemic once we had vaccines was that peer pressure, peer support, peer example would make people get vaccinated. And we're finding, it works for some people, not for a lot of people. What are we doing wrong? Oh, gosh. We could have a two-hour, we could have a two-day conversation about this. Yeah.
行为改变中。这就引出了疫苗接种率的问题，因为在疫情早期，一旦有了疫苗，许多人的想法是同伴压力、同伴支持、同伴榜样会促使人们去接种疫苗。然而我们发现，这对某些人有效，但对很多人并没有用。我们到底哪里做错了？哦，天哪。我们可以就此进行两个小时、甚至两天的对话。是的。
I don't think we were wrong that peer support social norms would matter for vaccinating. I actually think that's true. We just would have been naive to say, and here I'm coming back to problem solution matching, that for everyone, the barrier was going to be solved by seeing others around them getting vaccinated. Okay? So for some people, the reason you might not get a vaccine might be, well, gosh, this sounds sort of new and scary.
我不认为我们关于同伴支持和社会规范对接种疫苗很重要的看法是错的。实际上我认为那是对的。我们只是有点天真地认为——这里我又回到了问题与解决方案的匹配上——对每个人来说，这个障碍都可以通过看到周围其他人接种疫苗来解决。好吧？所以对某些人来说，你可能不接种疫苗的原因可能是，哦天哪，这听起来有点新而且可怕。
I don't know. We'll see if other people do it. If other people do it and it works out fine for them, maybe I'll feel more comfortable. and their peer norms are going to be really important. Seeing lots of, you know, selfies of people you trust or in your community taking this vaccine, that is going to help. And I think that did do a fair amount of work. If you look at surveys from a year ago, last September, only about half of Americans said they would feel comfortable getting a vaccine.
我不知道。我们看看其他人会不会这么做。如果其他人这么做而且对他们来说结果很好，也许我会觉得更舒服。他们的同伴规范将是非常重要的。看到很多，你知道的，你信任的人或你所在社区的人接种这种疫苗的自拍照，那将会有所帮助。我认为这确实发挥了相当大的作用。如果你看看一年前的调查，也就是去年9月，只有大约一半的美国人表示他们愿意接种疫苗。
And we're, you know, well past, we're past 70% of adults now having had their first shot. So that's more than half of Americans who had the opportunity to get a shot doing it, right? So we're way better off than we were a year ago. And I suspect part of that, I mean, there's so many things. But part of it may have had to do with seeing their peers, seeing, you know, hundreds of millions of people have done this. And now it feels comfortable. But the thing is, that wasn't the only barrier. There's misinformation, which is a major barrier.
而现在我们，你知道的，远不止于此，我们已经超过70%的成人接种了第一针。所以这比那些有机会接种却去接种的一半美国人还要多，对吧？所以我们的情况比一年前好多了。我怀疑部分原因，我的意思是，原因有很多，但部分原因可能与看到同龄人、看到数以亿计的人这样做了有关。现在这感觉让人安心了。但问题是，这并不是唯一的障碍。还有虚假信息，这是一个主要的障碍。
There's another barrier that I think is important to acknowledge, which is cost. There's real cost in terms of time off from work, having child. care, having symptoms that is important to acknowledge and recognize, especially in a country where we have so much income inequality, so much inequality of opportunity more generally. And just making something available for free is not covering all of the costs associated with it. So, you know, really wide range of different barriers. And so we need a lot of different solutions to overcome all of that.
我认为还有另一个需要承认的重要障碍，那就是成本。在请假、找育儿嫂以及出现症状方面，存在着真正的成本，这是非常重要且需要承认和认识到的，特别是在一个贫富差距如此之大、机会不平等更普遍的国家。仅仅让某种东西免费并不能涵盖与之相关的所有成本。所以，你知道的，确实存在非常广泛的不同障碍。因此我们需要许多不同的解决方案来克服所有这些问题。
And of course, it's been politicized, and that didn't help things. And I have lots of brilliant colleagues who could say much smarter things on this podcast about how to tackle that. That's not my specialty, but I do admire the great work being done in this field on the issues of polarization. And so what do we do from here? My team has spent a lot of time thinking in the last year and studying this problem and looking at different tactics from, we ran some, we call them mega studies, really, really massive randomized controlled trials where instead of testing a single hypothesis, we test literally dozens at the same time in parallel.
当然，这已经被政治化了，这无济于事。我有很多才华横溢的同事，他们可以在这个播客上发表更聪明的言论，谈谈如何应对这一问题。这不是我的专长，但我确实钦佩该领域在极化问题上所做的大量出色工作。那么我们接下来该做什么？我的团队在过去的一年里花了很多时间思考和研究这个问题，研究不同的策略，比如我们运行了一些我们称之为“超级研究”的项目——真正、真正大规模的随机对照试验，在这些试验中，我们不是测试单一假设，而是同时并行测试几十个假设。
We've run these studies with Walmart pharmacies and with two large healthcare systems to test out different text messaging communications, encouraging people to get a vaccine and see what worked best. We found a tactic that did then prove useful. We were studying it in the context of flu shots. last fall, hoping it would port over to COVID. And actually, I mentioned Hank Chen Dai when I was talking about flu shot. Excuse me, I was talking about the fresh start.
我们与沃尔玛药店和两个大型医疗系统合作开展了这些研究，以测试不同的短信沟通方式，鼓励人们接种疫苗并看看什么效果最好。我们发现了一种后来证明确实有用的策略。我们在去年秋天流感疫苗的背景下研究它，希望它能推广到新冠肺炎。实际上，当我谈到流感疫苗时，我提到了汉克·陈·戴（Hank Chen Dai）。对不起，我当时在谈论“新鲜起步”效应。
She took sort of a best performer from our two mega studies on flu shots and proved that it then was effective in encouraging COVID-19 vaccinations and had a paper about that come out in nature with Sylvia Sicado and some other co-authors in the last couple weeks. And that message was, it's waiting for you, it's reserved for you. It belongs to you. Come claim it. So an ownership message.
她采用了我们在流感疫苗的两项超级研究中表现最好的方法，并证明它在鼓励接种新冠疫苗方面同样有效，并且在过去几周里与西尔维娅·西卡多（Sylvia Sicado）和其他几位合著者在《自然》杂志上发表了一篇论文。那条信息是：它在等着你，它为你保留。它属于你。来领取吧。所以这是一个所有权的信息。
sort of conveys recommendation, uses the endowment effect or the fact that we value things more that we feel belong to us. And also probably makes it feel like it's not going to be a hassle because it's already been reserved for you. So I'm not going to have to fight to get mine. All of those things probably are part of what makes it work that we did not study the mechanism. We just showed in multiple large trials that this was sort of the top performer in a big suite of things we tested. So we've been recommending using it's reserved for you. language. I don't think at this point in the pandemic, that's going to solve the problem with vaccination. I don't think we just need text messages at this point. But it's like, it's one
这种方式传达了推荐，利用了禀赋效应（即我们更珍视那些感觉属于我们的东西的事实），并且可能也让人觉得这不是一件麻烦事，因为已经为你保留好了。所以我不需要为了得到我的疫苗而去争夺。所有这些因素可能都是它发挥作用的一部分，尽管我们并没有研究其具体机制。我们只是在多个大型试验中表明，这是我们测试过的一大堆方法中的顶级表现者。因此，我们一直建议使用“它已为您保留”这种语言。我不认为在疫情的这个阶段，这能解决疫苗接种的所有问题。我不认为我们现在仅仅需要短信。但这就像是其中一个
insight that we, and it may be helpful with things like second shots and booster shots to try to use that optimal language when we communicate about it. And it may counter some of the thinking around the fact that in the beginning it was very hard to get a shot. I mean, it wasn't there. You know, you had to make phone calls and find secret ways to. Big, yeah. Yes, can I get on your wait list? Could you please call me? I'll call you again tomorrow.
我们获得的见解，它可能对第二针和加强针等事情有所帮助，在就此进行沟通时尝试使用这种最佳语言。这可能会反驳最初很难打到疫苗这一事实所带来的某些想法。我的意思是，当时根本没有。你知道的，你必须打电话并寻找秘密渠道去……很大的挑战，是的。是的，我能上你们的候补名单吗？请你们能给我打个电话吗？我明天再打给你们。
Yeah. That's right. Yeah, but it's a different moment now, and I think we need different tools and tactics. Well, what about making lasting change for the long term? Are you recounted in the book a conversation you had with a physician friend where you lamented that in one of your experiments, you were able to get participants to go to the gym more often, but the effect wore off when we talked about that. a little while ago. And your friend said, we wouldn't expect to give someone with diabetes insulin
是的。没错。是的，但现在是不同的时刻了，我认为我们需要不同的工具和策略。那么，如何实现长期的持久改变呢？你在书中提到过与一位医生朋友的对话，你感叹在你的其中一个实验中，你能够让参与者更频繁地去健身房，但当我们谈到这个时，这种效果就逐渐消失了。不久前。你的朋友说，我们不会期望给糖尿病患者注射一次胰岛素
once and they're cured forever. And that makes sense. So what do we have to do to make lasting change? Does a change ever just stick without a conscious effort to maintain it? Yeah. It's a really wonderful question. I wish I had a really simple answer. I think, honestly, this is probably something I'll keep studying for the next, hopefully, 40 years of my life if I, if I eat right and exercise regularly and save well for retirement. So Kevin Volp is the scientist who made this great point to me. And it was sort of, oh, glaringly obvious once he said it, but it hadn't clicked for me before he pointed out that we shouldn't be treating behavior change as sort of a one and done. Like we would find a solution that was magical the way that you want to cure a rash, but that we
然后他们的病就永远治好了。这讲得通。那么我们必须做些什么才能实现持久的改变呢？如果不付出刻意的努力去维持，改变真的能一直保持下去吗？是的。这是一个非常棒的问题。我希望我能有一个非常简单的答案。老实说，我认为这可能是我在未来——希望是我生命的最后40年里——将继续研究的课题，前提是我饮食得当、经常锻炼并为退休攒好钱。所以凯文·沃尔普（Kevin Volp）就是那个向我指出这一伟大见解的科学家。一旦他指出来，这就显得极其显眼，但在他指出之前我并没有想通这一点：我们不应该把行为改变当作那种“一次性完成”的事情。就像我们会找到一种神奇的解决方案来治愈皮疹一样，而是我们
should think about behavior changes more like facing a chronic disease and trying to look for a suite of solutions because human nature doesn't just turn off, right? All of the barriers to change that I write about in the book, you don't, you can't just make them go away. You're going to be struggling with forgetfulness and procrastination and laziness for your whole life. I do think there's wonderful research on habits that occasionally suggests we can put things on autopilot. And I just want to sort of point to Wendy Wood of University of Southern California as I think the leading thinker in this area. And it does seem that there are certain things that we can put on autopilot to some degree following sort of, you know, the kind of reinforcement we've seen in
应该把行为改变看作是应对一种慢性病，并试图寻找一套解决方案，因为人性不会就此关闭，对吧？我在书中写的所有关于改变的障碍，你无法、也无法让它们凭空消失。你将在你的一生中与健忘、拖延和懒惰作斗争。我确实认为，关于习惯的精彩研究偶尔表明我们可以将某些事情置于自动驾驶状态。我只想顺便指出南加州大学的温迪·伍德（Wendy Wood），我认为她是这一领域的主要思想家。似乎确实有些事情在某种程度上可以置于自动驾驶状态，遵循我们在
animal models, right, that you, if you engage in the behavior and then you receive a reward and then you repeat and you do this enough times, certain things do become automatic, like making coffee, in the morning or, right? Or shampooing your hair, flossing your teeth, uh, hand sanitizing if you're a caregiver in a hospital. These are the kinds of things that do seem to be where it is possible to really habituate it and,
动物模型中看到的强化机制，对吧？如果你参与这种行为，然后你得到奖励，然后你重复，你这样做足够多次，某些事情确实会变得自动化，就像早晨煮咖啡一样，对吧？或者洗头、用牙线清洁牙齿、如果你是医院的看护人员那么进行手部消毒。这些似乎确实是能够真正养成习惯的事情，并且
and have it for the most part continue. But I think most things require, most of the things we care about in life. And, and also you can put on autopilot, right, your, your retirement savings. So there are some magic exceptions. But I do think a lot of the goals. goals we have in life. A lot of the things that require effort and thought and deliberation, it's going to be very hard to autopilot them. I'm not sure it's possible. And instead, what I have come to appreciate as the right path to change is to create structures and strategies
在大多数情况下会持续下去。但我认为大多数事情都需要，我们在生活中关心的绝大多数事情。而且，你也可以将你的退休储蓄置于自动驾驶状态，对吧？所以确实有一些神奇的例外。但我确实认为我们在生活中拥有的很多目标。很多需要付出努力、思考和深思熟虑的事情，要将它们完全置于自动驾驶状态是非常困难的。我不确定这是否可能。相反，我开始认识到通往改变的正确路径是建立结构和策略
that you're okay relying on to help you get through the barriers just permanently, right? So, for instance, I still temptation bundled to go to the gym. And that works for me. Well, during COVID, I haven't been going to a gym. But to get my exercise in, I look for ways to do that and always will. And I don't feel like I needed to ever end that strategy, right? So some of the, I'll call them crutches that we can use to get ourselves to succeed, like accountability or temptation bundling as we've talked about. There's no need to set them aside.
你可以依靠这些结构和策略来帮助你永久地度过这些障碍，对吧？例如，我仍然使用“诱惑捆绑法”去健身房。这对我很有用。嗯，在疫情期间，我没有去健身房。但为了锻炼身体，我一直在寻找这样做的方法，而且永远都会这样。我不觉得我需要结束这种策略，对吧？所以一些，我称之为我们可以用来帮助自己取得成功的“拐杖”，比如问责制或我们讨论过的诱惑捆绑法。没有必要把它们抛在一边。
There's no need to say, I'm going to use this for a month. And then I'll be off to the races and I won't need this tactic anymore. Instead, I think we should expect to use them forever. and not see that as a downside. It's just that's, you know, we need these tools to achieve our goals and we should keep using them. And that's how we get where we want to be. And there's always another good book to listen to. Absolutely. Yes. You'll never run out. That is a wonderful thing about entertainment. There's so much of it. So what next? What are the big questions that you're looking to answer now? Thank you. That's a great question. I mean, the last year has been truly very focused for my team on the issue. of vaccination and COVID-19. And we're, you know, working on some papers right now about that. We've been, we launched a vaccine sweepstakes in my hometown of Philadelphia in partnership with the city government that we designed using a regret lottery, which is a very specific type of lottery that, um, capitalizes on people's fear of regret. So everyone in the city was
没有必要说，我打算用这个一个月，然后我就会一飞冲天，不再需要这个战术了。相反，我认为我们应该期望永远使用它们，而不要将此视为缺点。只是，你知道的，我们需要这些工具来达成目标，我们应该继续使用它们。这就是我们如何到达我们想去的地方。而且总有一本好书可以听。绝对的。是的。你永远不会听完。这是娱乐的一个美妙之处。它太丰富了。那么接下来呢？你现在希望回答的重大问题是什么？谢谢。这是一个很好的问题。我的意思是，在过去的一年里，我的团队真正非常专注于
automatically entered and they could get a phone call that their name had been drawn, but they would have to decline the prize if they couldn't prove they'd been vaccinated. So We were, you know, the idea is how much would you regret getting that call, finding out you had won the grand prize and having to decline it, that just that visceral fantasy of the anticipated regret might motivate some extra people to go get a vaccine above and beyond what you'd see in a typical standard lottery where you're only entered if you're eligible because you've gotten a vaccine. So we've done that and we had sort of randomly assigned zip codes that actually had extra probabilities of winning. So we're working on analyzing that and trying to be able to come out with some policy
疫苗接种和新冠肺炎的问题。而且我们，你知道的，目前正在撰写一些关于这方面的论文。我们一直在，我们在我的家乡费城与市政府合作发起了一场疫苗抽奖活动，我们使用遗憾彩票（regret lottery）设计了这个活动，这是一种非常特殊的彩票类型，它利用了人们对遗憾的恐惧。所以城里的每个人都
recommendations for what are the best practices that we can use at this phase in the pandemic, and as we roll out probably booster shots, and as other countries reach the phase we've reached. But really looking further forward than, you know, the next couple months, I think we sort of touched on it a bit in your prior question. You asked about enduring behavior change. And I still, even though I gave you an answer that I do completely agree with, you know, I believe in very much that the answer is we keep using these tools. I still study often tactics that an employer or a school or, you know, a gym, you know, an organization that's trying to help people create positive lasting change can wrap around beneficiaries to help them achieve that durably. And so I'm looking into like what are the tools that those kinds of organizations can offer to their employees, their members, their students that will carry them forward for as long as possible. And what are the kinds of features of programming that make it the most effective?
自动参与了，他们可能会接到电话得知自己的名字被抽中了，但如果他们无法证明自己已经接种了疫苗，就必须拒绝这个奖品。所以我们，你知道的，这个想法是：你会多么遗憾接到那个电话，发现自己赢得了大奖却不得不拒绝它，仅仅是那种对预期遗憾的直观幻想可能会激励一些额外的人去接种疫苗，超越你在典型标准彩票中看到的效果（在标准彩票中，只有因为接种了疫苗而符合资格的人才能参与）。所以我们已经做了这个，并且我们随机分配了实际具有额外中奖概率的邮政编码。所以我们正在努力分析这一点，并试图提出一些政策建议
You know, is it mindset? Is it social? Are there other tactics we haven't studied yet that do create more lasting change? So I'm really eager to explore that. I'm also really interested in understanding better when people have goal failure, how they stand up again. You know, fresh starts are part of it, of course. And there's other tactics in the book, too.
关于我们在疫情的这个阶段可以使用哪些最佳实践，以及当我们推出加强针时，以及当其他国家达到我们已经到达的阶段时。但更长远地看，不仅仅是未来几个月，我想我们在你之前的问题中已经触及了一点。你问到了持久的行为改变。我仍然，尽管我给你的答案是我完全同意的，你知道的，我非常相信答案是我们继续使用这些工具。我仍然经常研究那些雇主、学校或，你知道的，健身房，你知道的，试图帮助人们创造积极持久改变的组织可以围绕受益人构建的策略，以帮助他们持久地实现这一目标。所以我正在研究这类组织可以向员工、会员、学生提供哪些工具，以便尽可能长时间地支持他们前进。以及什么样的编程特性才能使其最有效？
But I think recovering from failure is under, it's so important because we almost always fail when we set out to achieve a goal at least once. We have to get back up again if we're going to get to our final destination. And I think there's a lot more to know about how to do that. Well, Dr. Milkman, this has been really interesting. I think you're doing extraordinarily important work, and I want to thank you for joining us today. Thank you so much for having me. This was a really fun conversation. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.combeatingof Psychology.org
你知道，是心态吗？是社交吗？还有其他我们尚未研究过的、能创造更持久改变的策略吗？所以我真的很渴望去探索这一点。我也非常想更好地理解当人们遭遇目标失败时，他们是如何重新站起来的。你知道，重新开始当然是其中的一部分。书中也有其他策略。
or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts, and please, where you can, leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但我认为从失败中恢复过来被低估了，这太重要了，因为当我们着手实现一个目标时，我们几乎总是至少失败一次。如果我们想到达最终目的地，我们必须重新站起来。我认为关于如何做到这一点还有很多需要了解的地方。好的，米尔克曼博士，这真的非常有趣。我认为你正在做非同寻常的重要工作，我想感谢你今天加入我们。非常感谢邀请我。这是一次非常愉快的对话。你可以在 www.combeatingof Psychology.org 找到《心理学之谈》往期节目